hi dr. Wallach thank you for taking my
call so I have some issues so with my
husband he takes the cardio effects and
the ultimate daily classics for his
heart if he doesn't take that you know
he his heart gets weak he has hip pain
and he can't do much cardio but these
two have helped him is there anything
else that he can take for that is he
taking the 90 in addition to the cardio
FX and the ultimate sales masticore
that's it
no he I mean he takes several
supplements he takes both of the
ultimate the EF ace selenium gluco gel
sweet ease the tangy tangerine Bianca
tangy okay in the osteo FX liquid yeah
okay okay they're taking the basic
program plus these do that okay it's
equally important to stay away from the
bad stuff the fried foods the process
needs the oils the glutens right gotta
take the pressure off the heart and the
blood vessels yeah and let's see here
does he have any respiratory problems or
have a pressure diabetes anything like
that no he's a healthy man other than
you know the heart it doesn't take any
you know medications either okay does he
have a diagnosis I mean when you say
it's a heart problem is this does he
have plank in his arteries does he have
atrial fibrillation
does he have congestive heart failure
what has he got he does not but he's
just on these supplements because if he
doesn't take that you know like I said
his heart gets weak when he does cardio
like the next day he can't even get up
he has low energy mm-hmm
but these two did he take you know okay
now is he taking the rebound for a fluid
and electrolyte replacement when he
exercises no okay should take the
rebound this is our sports drink with a
hundred nutrients and it replaces the
things he's sweating out and you know
Gatorade has two nutrients some power he
has six and ours has 100 and of course
we have it and the individual servings
where you can add to a bottle of water
there's no carbonation in it which I'd
recommend the cans do we have about 10%
of the carbonation of the soft drink and
so in his case I would go with the
individual servings which are in the
a little we call them six little pouches
that there's thirty in a box and so he
exercises you might want to take two of
those per exercise sessions so he'd need
to those 30 count boxes per month of
rebound as her sports drink again and I
do want him to eat a protein okay he can
what is he weigh by the way he's about
180 he's 510
okay so that's pretty good all right and
he should be eating eggs he should be
eating eggs I want him to eat about four
to six eggs twice a day they could be in
a smoothie or a shake we have the
slender FX shake we have the strawberry
cream shake we have the bone broth okay
when she can make with a heavy whipping
cream which will be good for his heart
and good for energy as well and and so I
would kind of go that direction we don't
admit to lose any more weight so I would
make it with a heavy whipping cream
instead of water and add that to his
dietary program so he has some proteins
and fats and things and solicitous start
there and then call me every two weeks
on him or anytime you have a question
what's the second one the second issue
is he for the past year now he's had
very dry skin so from his eyes you know
to his legs but the groin area is always
sweaty really you know wet what's life
okay does he have a history of any
respiratory problems when he was a kid
or a teenager did he have like asthma
bronchitis no did he have any skin
problems such as eczema dermatitis
psoriasis or just the dry skin you know
just the dry skin even like in the
morning he can't open his eyes because
they're so dry that's it you know that's
why I'm sure what about things like um
about plums any have any diverticulitis
and the situs colitis also requires
leaky gut syndrome anything like that no
consultation no diarrhea no okay very
good
well again I'd get him off all the bad
foods no fried foods okay get rid of the
free radicals absolutely no processed
meats no deli slices sandwich meats
sausage ham bacon Bologna salami
Rahmi pepperoni jerky karma spam all
that's gotta go then I get him off of
all the oils just the opposite of what
other people would tell you he needs to
get on all the oils it means absolutely
no olive oil coconut all Martin's
mayonnaise celtris cooking oils they
tend to oxidize turn into trans fats
heterocycle means
acrylamide which cause plaque in the
arteries can cause free radical damage
everywhere including the skin in the
eyes and so so none of those invent no
gluten no wheat no bar around oats the
agents don't have half the disease as we
do not because of genetics but because
they live on rice and sweet potatoes
they come over here and live on wheat
brother I notes like us to get all our
diseases they go back to Asia go back on
rice and sweet potatoes all their
diseases go away and so we got to get
rid of the wheat bran around oats out of
the diet and you do have something for
skin and it's called hair skin and nails
you could take three of those twice a
day those two bottles a month we also
have a topical skin line which is called
sole purpose it's made made from the
shea butter as a kind of a big seed in
West Africa and it's a saturated fat
from plants very unusual it's a
saturated fat from plants and we like to
use that on dry skin okay and it
wouldn't hurt for him to go to pharmacy
a lot of prescription he can get the
artificial tears and stuff like that
from a pharmacy got a prescription but
then his eyes here four times a day